phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
meine gäste zunächst hier im studio
claus strunz ist bei uns journalist und
fernsehmoderator mitglied der bild
chefredaktion und dort verantwortlich
für das bewegtbildangebot midlife
albrecht von lucke
politikwissenschaftler und publizist
redakteur bei der politischen
monatszeitschrift blätter für deutsche
und internationale politik zugeschaltet
aus der akademie für politische bildung
in tutzing professorin ursula münch und
schließlich martin herrenknecht bei uns
der gründer und vorstandsvorsitzende der
herrenknecht ag einem hersteller von
tunnelvortriebsmaschine zum tunnelbau
und sie sind auch mitglied der cdu
herrscht uns wird es die cdu noch
bereuen
armin laschet gewählt haben das ist eine
gute frage ich glaube jedenfalls dass
armin laschet nur mit einem instrument
gelingen kann die cdu zu einen und zwar
mit erfolg und ich kann im moment nichts
sehen wo er den her holen will im
schatten der kanzlerin
schon jetzt kann man auch andersrum
fragen kann die cdu nur mit laschet an
der spitze die hoffnung hegen weiterhin
die führende politische kraft in
deutschland zu bleiben also die cdu
meines erachtens hat tatsächlich nur
armin laschet den neu gewählten
parteivorsitzenden
aber natürlich kann man noch zur
bayerischen schwesterpartei schauen
jemand anderen sehe ich zumindest seit
dem debakel von zwei personen beim
parteitag nicht mehr glück haben denn
annalena baerbock und olaf scholz beim
sieg von armin laschet einen schluckauf
bekommen sie haben sich sicherlich nicht
gefreut und deswegen kann ich vom nicht
nur zustimmen das was viele glaube
herrenknecht hat uns auch wohl
präferiert hätten nämlich die wahl von
friedrich merz
das wäre die polarisierung die
politisierung eines wahlkampfes gewesen
wir hätten uns das direkt aus demokratie
theoretischen gründen wünschen können es
waren aber hier eher wirtschaftsliberale
oder
neben dass auch wirtschafts radikale
gründe die dafür sprechen der friedrich
merz für den gebotenen kandidaten zu
halten der hätte aber eine derartige
polarisierung erzeugt und übrigens in
das sei auch gesagt an der stelle er hat
offensichtlich auch kenntlich gemacht
dass ihm das der sinn nicht primär nach
der partei statt sondern alleine danach
in amt und würden zu kommen ins
kanzleramt zu zählen und ich glaube
alleine der akt den friedrich merz
danach nach der wahl von ami laschet
getätigt hat sollte für alle
vermeintlich wertkonservativen anders zu
sein anzunehmen dass er
märz kein sonderlich wert konnte er
wollte durchziehen und er hat mit dem er
formulierte ich will jetzt
wirtschaftsminister werden kenntlich
gemacht dass nun eine integrative rolle
eine nicht polarisierende rolle völlig
ab gehen insofern war armin laschet die
richtige wahl
die grünen frau berg und der arbeit
wären sich sehr ärgern denn natürlich
wäre friedrich merz so etwas wie eine
lose kennen wie eine lockere kanone an
bord der cdu gewesen und das ist ja
übrigens weiterhin und das macht armin
laschet noch viel arbeit dass wir gleich
noch vertiefen dieses thema herrenknecht
als cdu-mitglied wenn ich das richtig
gelesen habe ist in die cdu im moment ja
eigentlich zu links aber glauben sie
wirklich dass ein dominant konservativ
wirtschafts liberales profil in
deutschland mehrheitsfähig ist
also ist es kein geheimnis ich habe bei
eindeutiger märz gesetzt märz verkörpert
für mich der wirtschaftsfachmann wenn
wir heute anschauen wie es zugeht mit
der pandemie milliarden vom himmel
geströmt nach halt geld nach
herausgegeben für die pandemie können
wir die wirtschaft nur dann wirklich
wieder in gang bringen wenn wir ein
wirtschaftsfachmann haben aus diesem
grunde aber ich als märz gesetz klar die
wahl ist anders ausgegangen vielleicht
ein kleiner vorteil märz gemacht hat das
als wirtschaftsminister sich angedient
hat was absolut unmöglich ist es wäre
besser gewesen hat er gesagt mit der
neuen regierung ab september
superminister für wirtschaft und
finanzen könnte ich mir gut vorstellen
aber die tatsache ist jetzt das lasse
das haben wir gewählt ist und eine
demokratie letztes mal wollte ich aus
der cdu rausgehen dieses mal bleibe ich
als mitglied in der cdu trenne er hat
meine fragen meine frage ging ja dahin
friedrich merz mit seinem politischen
profil überhaupt chancen hat eine
bundestagswahl zu gewinnen
also ich glaube schon dass die chance
gehabt hätte nachher weil wenn wir jetzt
aus der pandemie rauskommt müssen wir
alle sehen die wirtschaft setzen und für
mich ist der wirtschaftsmann der sich
gut auskennt nachher und treten jetzt
nicht gewählt ist jetzt müssen wir
schauen wie wir mit laschet klar kommt
und als dem grunde müssen wir überlegen
wie wir taktisch vorgehen
es kursiert ja unter märz anhängen cdu
im netz ein bild eine fotomontage
genauer sagen mit dem körperbau von
angela merkel und obendrauf ist der kopf
von armin laschet und die raute fehlt
auch nicht ist armin laschet der
wiedergänger von angela merkel
naja jedenfalls hat er bisher selber
darauf wert gelegt hat sich ja oft
geäußert auf die frage was er anders
machen werde als die kanzlerin nichts
das ist selten eindeutig äußerungen
eines politikers der in ein so hohes amt
strebt und damit hat er natürlich ein
teil der menschen in seiner partei
erschreckt und in der bürger der
möglichen wähler auch aber ich glaube
dass die schizophrenie der cdu darin
besteht dass der kurs von armin laschet
in der partei wesentlich weniger
mehrheitsfähig ist als im land also
insofern müsste sich die partei dazu
überwinden anzuerkennen wie die
stimmungen im land sind und dann auf
laschet setzen
ich glaube übrigens so wird es auch
kommen aber es sei denn laschet ist also
lasse das aus meiner sicht der einzige
der lastet noch verhindern kann
aber diese macht politische orientierung
eigentlich ist wichtig nicht wie in der
partei es aussieht sondern im land man
könnte ja auch das sprichwort anführen
der wurm muss dem fisch schmecken und
nicht dem angler ist dass sie diese
macht politische dimension auch der
grund dafür dass die cdu 51 von 71
jahren den bundeskanzler gestellt naja
wenn man so dominant das land regiert zu
viele jahrzehnte dann
kann man ja nicht so wahnsinnig viel
falsch gemacht haben bei der frage
sozusagen den den mainstream und die
mehrheiten im land zu spüren und was die
menschen wirklich bewegt aber ich komme
noch mal auf den punkt ich glaube an
dieser schizophrenie der cdu kann man
eine fehlstellung der ganzen politik
beobachten also sozusagen das ist ein
eigentlich sagt etwas salopp ein verein
der nach anderen prinzipien sich
zusammensetzt als denen nach denen es
sich zusammensetzen sollte nämlich
nachdem wie es da draußen im land zugeht
und ich glaube mit blick auf den
unternehmer in unserer runde dass mit
der kalten schneidigen ceo attitüde ich
gehe jetzt mal durch und wir müssen das
so und so machen die friedrich merz
selbst wenn sein herz vielleicht ein
bisschen anders schlägt jedenfalls
verkörpert wird man in der mehrheit der
bevölkerung nichts das heißt dass ich
jetzt gerade geschildert wie die cdu die
spd jetzt genau umgekehrt gemacht und
waren hat nur 20 jahre lang dem kanzler
gestellt frau münch wenn wir kurz noch
bei armin laschet bleiben ist er zu nah
an angela merkel dran oder hat er auch
ein alleinstellungsmerkmal mit dem er
jetzt in der cdu profil gewinnen kann
naja deutlicher unterschied angela
merkel ist ja schon mal sein geschlecht
damit verbirgt sich und verbindet sich
schon mal gewisse unterschiede
er ist ein völlig anderer typ er tritt
völlig anders auf er spricht die leute
völlig anders an
er geht anders nicht nur mit der partei
um sondern auch mit der wählerschaft um
da gibt es sicherlich viele
überschneidungen mit blick auf
politische inhalte aber sein politikstil
ist ein komplett anderer seine herkunft
ist eine andere
also ich sehe viele unterschiede
zwischen herrn laschet und frau merkel
wird sie nur nicht wenn ich das sagen
darf mit einer äußerung von heute von
frau merkel
sie ist heute gefragt worden wie sie das
jetzt eigentlich machen will die letzten
monate ihrer amtszeit und dann hat sich
ausdrücklich gesagt sie ist bis zum
letzten tag ihres amtes im amt und so
regiert sie und da ist sozusagen auch
kein platz für irgendjemand anderen in
diesem langen schatten möchte ich als
partei wird jetzt wird sich
ich gesagt dass eine bundes ich hoffe
dass eine bundeskanzlerin bis zum
letzten tag regiert aber letzten aber
wir haben sie nicht aber was bedeutet
das für den cdu plänen aber sie
verstehen aber glaube ich was ich meine
das bedeutet für den cdu vorsitzenden
armin laschet dass er keinen millimeter
spielraum hat eigene akzente zu setzen
sich von ihr abzusetzen neue felder zu
der mann ist sozusagen im schwarzen
schatten von angela merkel paralysiert
gleicher weise ist einfach das feld
gelandet hatte der bundestag kommt heute
gesagt sie will ihm diese luft zum atmen
schon lassen also na ja das hab ich ja
so verstellt das ist aber gut gemeint
was heißt das in der tat da gebe ich
einen stoß recht die möglichkeiten von
armin laschet und er hat übrigens keine
sechs monate mehr
doch ganz klar die zeit in der ami
laschet sich profilieren muss in zwei
monate er muss sich bis zur entscheidung
von cdu/csu ende märz profilieren
das ist gar nichts und ich will ein
zweites hinzufügen armin laschet hat
frau münch hat wunderbar die
unterschiede heraus gestellt man würde
sogar noch dazu setzen ausgesprochen
rheinländisch jovial kein physiker also
ich will sagen weit weniger kantig als
frau merkte er hat aber einen ganz
großen fehler gemacht er hat nämlich im
letzten jahr und das war die eigentliche
große fehlerhaftigkeit von armin laschet
in dem augenblick auf distanz von angela
merkel gesetzt
an der an dem ein anderer sofort erkannt
hat als absoluter magna will ist und
kenner des politischen geschäfts ich
muss an merkel ranrücken wie kein
anderer an dem augenblick nämlich wo es
mit der korona pandemie einsetzte wo
merkel plötzlich die sympathien zu
flogen wie nie zuvor seit fünf jahren
die große wende für merkel in dem
augenblick hat armin laschet versucht
den lockerer gegen merkel zu spielen
gegen die harte linie hat er versucht
sich abzusetzen er wurde zu dem lockeren
im lande hat damit seine schlechtes
lockeres image noch unterstrichen
und er hat sich eben gerade nicht zu dem
richtigen zeitpunkt an die seite der
kanzlerin gestellt was genau ein anderer
gemacht hat jeden tag und seitdem jeden
tag bundespolitik macht das ist markus
söder markus söder hat diese chance ex
exzellent erkannt wir müssen bewusst
machen er spielt seit einem jahr
bundesliga
das ist der glücksfall gewesen dass er
chef der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
war jeden tag im fernsehen kein tag
vergeht an dem markt an den mann markus
söder nicht sid herr laschet ist in der
zeit weitgehend unsichtbar geblieben
abgesehen für das rheinländische
publikum
er ist nur negativ aufgefallen am anfang
hören
und er hat sich nicht profilieren können
im gleichen maße das heißt die zwei
monate die jetzt bleiben um noch
bundespolitische statur zu gewinnen sind
so knapp dass ich nicht sehe dass er in
den zwei monaten den abstellungen markus
söder wird aufhören können und dann
fällt die entscheidung für die cdu/csu
ziemlich leicht ich freue mich ganz kurz
das sehe ich komplett anders helfern
lucke und ich glaube auch nicht dass ein
kurs der alice gewisses hinterfragen der
korona bewältigung politik betreibt dass
der von vornherein schlecht in der
bevölkerung ankommt es gibt auch viele
menschen denen söder einfach immer zu
viel noch mal eins drauf legt und
abgesehen davon ändert der aktionismus
von herrn söder nichts an der tatsache
dass die csu die kleinere von beiden
parteien ist
ich würde die maschine ausgetauscht ich
würde gern noch auf einen anderen aspekt
noch auf sie kommen aus den da der
offenbar ja armin laschet noch nicht die
autorität in der partei gewonnen hat
obwohl er gewählt worden ist vielleicht
auch noch mal auf friedrich merz neben
der knapp unterlegen ist eigentlich doch
ganz gut abgeschnitten hat und kurz nach
dieser wahl
armin laschet glaube ich als erstes
gefragt hat gezittert hat jetzt bin ich
bereit wirtschaftsminister zu werten
aber in einer relativ deutlichen form
hat er damit gezeigt dass er sich
vielleicht für als ich für ein hohes
politisches amt doch nicht so eignet als
er jetzt noch mal zwei wahlen gab dann
und lodges gewählt wir können ja nicht
in der cdu jetzt noch den nächsten
wahlkampf machen um eben nachher zu
entscheiden ob jetzt nach hat das oder
jenes kommt wenn sie anschauen ist es
ganz klar dass wir jetzt landtagswahlen
in baden württemberg die gilt es zu
gewinnen gegenüber die krümel schwierig
bei kretschmann rheinland pfalz es gibt
jetzt in den nächsten zwei monaten
selber die chance die cdu zu bewähren
und nach auch die cdu wieder
zusammenzuführen
eines ist klar was ich vermute
und auch was ich hier sehe das im osten
märz
nach germanist der auch die afc etwas in
die ecke treiben könnte und das sei in
baden württemberg sind viel sympathien
für märz gewesen jetzt haben halten die
wahl noch gehabt glaskästen werden
können nicht noch lang diskutieren ob
man jetzt nochmals eine wahl machen
ich glaube und muss sagen dass die cdu
einen vorbildlichen digitalen nach katar
weiter geführt hat dann zieh mir und ich
muss sagen die cdu ist jetzt wieder
modernen geworden und jetzt müssen wir
das personalproblem logic ist vorn
müssen wir lösen und müssen schauen wie
wir märz einbinden können und das ist
meine strategie auf der anderen seite
bin ich auch überzeugt wenn wir cdu 30
35 prozent haben die csu 5 prozent kann
es doch nicht sein dass dann die csu den
kanzlerkandidat stellt das war damals
etwas kritisch wo man sammle stoiber
aufgestellt hat und strauß war die
chance als cdu/csu zu gewinnen war
relativ gering aber heute ist doch
position so dass die cdu mit großem
abstand nachher die partei ist die den
kanzlerkandidaten stellen sollte
und ich glaube wir müssen einfach jetzt
eine strategie fahren das mit lasche wir
ins rennen gehen und auch schauen dass
wir wollen gewinnen und gesang
deutlicher weise
sie haben von den letzten zehn minuten
der phoenix runde vorweggenommen werden
diese punkte alle noch anständig macht
es doch zum zweiten anlauf zu friedrich
merz es geht um einbindung sagt der
herrenknecht kann es sein dass er sich
noch einbinden lässt
wie sieht das aus oder wird er
möglicherweise in der versenkung
verschwinden weil sie haben im grunde
finde ich die antwort schon mit der
anfrage drin
ich glaube es kann sein dass er sich
noch einbinden lässt aber es wird
unglaubwürdig wirken weil es ja klar ist
dass friedrich merz auf das kanzleramt
gezielt hat und selbst der
wirtschaftsminister den er so voll
bricht da ins gespräch gebracht hat als
der sich ins gespräch gebracht hat ist
ja so eine art trostpreis friedrich merz
ist angetreten um kanzlerkandidaten und
kanzler zu werden
die partei hat ihm jetzt besser gesagt
die delegierten der partei da muss man
vielleicht auch noch mal auf den feinen
unterschied machen die delegierten der
partei haben es eben jetzt zweimal
schriftlich gegeben dass er nicht ihr
mann ist und deshalb glaube ich also ich
ganz persönlich glaube friedrich merz
mit der cdu gar nichts mehr
eine peinliche figur bin ich absolut
nicht überzeugt nachher von der
situation wenn sie frauen in den neuen
bundesländern hat
märz eine gute reputation ich glaube
auch dass er doch für die cdu und guten
wahlkampf führen können wir auch in
baden württemberg braucht es selber
wirtschaftsexperten klassik ist nun
gewählt da werden wir nichts dran ändern
wir müssen jetzt schauen dass wir die
landtagswahlen gewinnen vor allem in
baden württemberg gut abschneiden weil
es schwierig ist gegen kretschmann gerne
halten den guten landesvater ist dort zu
bestehen das wird noch eine entscheidung
geben aber ich glaube schon dass merz
nachher der cdu gut helfen könnte also
sagen aber auf der anderen seite wenn du
zweimal wenn du zweimal verlierst war
das infoboard den wirtschaftsminister in
den raum zu werfen wo jeder normale
bürger sagen muss dass das blödsinn war
es ist nachher dann eine situation wird
wird ich mir persönlich wünschen wenn im
september nachher wir die wahl gewinnen
die cdu und märz wirtschafts und
finanzminister wird und superminister
das wäre die kombination das können dass
er bleiben muss abwarten ich würde gerne
noch einmal auf die wunderwaffe märz in
ostdeutschland eingehen frau münch ein
saarländischer katholik klassischer west
die klassische cdu sowie sie sich seit
adenauers zeiten herausgebildet hat er
ist der prototyp dafür und das ist der
große freund des ostens eine
ungewöhnliche konstruktion und
bestritten das ist ungewöhnlich aber
gleichzeitig gebe ich an
ich gehe von herrenknecht recht das also
märz natürlich in den ostdeutschen
landesverbänden durchaus gut ankam diese
ja doch auch klare position mit blick
auf migrationspolitik auf die
gesellschaftspolitik auch diese
abwendung von angela merkels position in
der cdu das kommt in den ostdeutschen
landesverbänden durchaus gut an
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich
eine schwierigkeit wie bindet man
friedrich merz ein
und diese aussicht die wir gerade
skizziert bekommen haben dass man eben
gleich sogar noch ein superministerium
anbietet naja soviel positionen wird ein
kanzler ein bundeskanzler armin laschet
nicht zu verteilen haben der hat nämlich
dann auch noch an einen
koalitionspartner zu denken
der nicht so schlecht abschneiden wird
wie jetzt die spd könnte man das noch
ein bisschen zuspitzen erweitern davon
locken sagen
unruhestifter möchte der mögliche
bundeskanzler laschet gar nicht im
kabinett haben
das ist ja eine völlig jetzt erstmal
unerhebliche frage die entscheidende
frage ist muss er ihn einbinden
ich rede übrigens nicht vom
bundeskanzler laschet der wird es
übrigens auch nicht werden
das werde ich gleich vielleicht nur in
einem satz sagen dürfen er braucht aber
offensichtlich er braucht aber
offensichtlich herr laschet und das ist
ja schon eine kränkung für ein rascheres
übrigens auf einer frau herr laschet der
brüskiert wurde von herrn merz bis
dorthin aus muss in einer weise sich
bemühen diese nun ruhestörer und das ist
weit mehr als um ruhestörung eine
unrealistische verhaltensweise so sagen
ich habe zweimal verloren
nach dem alten neoliberalen oder
wirtschaftsliberalen spruch leistung
muss sich wieder lohnen versagen muss
sich wieder lohnen jetzt bin ich bereit
zu sagen jetzt will ich daraufhin
natürlich darauf wirtschaftsminister ist
musste für einen wirtschaftsliberalen
doch eine gewisse irritation erfuhren
aber das ist doch keine angst the heavy
ja da hat er wunderbar sind ja immer
einer meinung ist ja schön dass es
bringt uns ja auch deswegen spaß er hat
nahm daraufhin gesagt das ist vielleicht
der große glücksfall flasche das ist
mich ein kanadisches moment führen
gewesen er hat wohl auch gemerkt hat
dann eine irritation gesprochen hat
gesagt ich habe irritationen hervorrufen
man kann das auch anders sein er hat
sich damit für die kanzlerschaft glaube
ich absolut natürlich ist qualifiziert
er ist raus aus dem rennen
aber ich glaube nicht dass die
ambitionen von friedrich merz durchaus
noch mal vielleicht und da glaube ich
hat herr herrenknecht durchaus recht
deckt er kann sich vieles in einem
großen ministerium vorstellen vom typus
clement kann man sich da manches
vorstellen also ein superministerium
wenn herrn und ich glaube eben nicht
dass herr laschet sein wird aber wenn es
gelingt und herr söder ringt längst auch
der nämlich auch gesagt wenn ich brauche
den mann im team
märz gilt und das sieht man ja an
herrenknecht ergeht für eine als
regelrechter ist eine wunderbar für sie
haben den richtigen begriff er hat eine
wirkliche aura die unverrückbar ist 47
prozent sind ja ein fund es gibt zwei
parteien in der cdu und diese 47 prozent
die ihn immer noch gewählt haben die
kann keiner der kandidaten wer auch
immer es sein wird nicht versuchen ein
zu binden deswegen werden alle um
friedrich merz tun und wenn er sagt ja
ich bin bereit mich als ein
schattenkabinett des nächsten
kanzlerkandidaten einzubinden würde das
tun das hat scheinen sie hier verlieren
aber sie gehen ganz anderen
adressatenkreis ich meine frau münchen
finde es interessant dass sie das so
wahrnehmen ich glaube dass der
adressatenkreis wir offensichtlich von
herrn merz angesprochen wurde und ich
will sie sind ja so entschieden dass ich
jetzt im team wählen das ist doch
überall herr merz hat aber
offensichtlich einen erstaunlichen booms
mit den worten zu sprechen und gefragt
der typus merzig willst auch da noch mal
deutlich machen ist deshalb so attraktiv
weil er mit dem wunsch harte kante zu
verkörpern
das hat eben mit der frage ob er aus dem
saarland kommt für die aussies beispiel
so ostdeutschen gar nichts mehr ist
körper tat bekannte das versprechen ich
halbiere euch die afd
diesen typus verkörpert übrigen seien
armin laschet dezidiert nicht deswegen
war armin laschet schon bemüht haben
bosbach in sein kabinett in ordnung es
braucht diesen typus und ich glaube
deswegen wie gesagt auch nicht dass
armin laschet der kanzlerkandidaten wird
weil es noch einen anderen kannte ihren
gibt auf den kombi aber stört noch aber
der typus märz wird um gut weil er diese
populistische anmutung verkörpert und
den braucht offensichtlich ein teil der
partei um diesen parteien mal im alten
zeiten haben jetzt ganz wichtig wir
müssen die sendezeit der gerechte
verteilung zwischen armin laschet
schmerz und markus söder herrenknecht
ganz kurz wenn sie sich ganz kurz zu
fassen können so fühlt sich letzten
kehren wir wieder so armin laschet
zurück
ich möchte ich möchte nur mal auf
ereignis verweisen lassen
in nordrhein westfalen hatten starken
innenminister freude und entsteigen
laumann arbeitnehmervertreter dann der
hat ja auch schon zwei starke typen in
seinem kabinett von der seite ist es
nicht so von ferne zu ziehen wenn er
dann den märz zum beispiel als
wirtschafts und finanzminister 11 neue
kabinett nicht jetzt sondern september
wir haben jetzt ja denn so eine
bestandsaufnahme der aktuellen cdu
gerade gemacht was wo überall baustellen
sind armin laschet holz den auftrag die
partei zu einen wir haben die fragen in
der sendung kann er diese partei eine er
hat ja den nimbus eines brückenbauers
eines integrators möglicherweise hat ihm
das ja dann letztendlich auch zum sieg
verholfen auf dem parteitag wird er wird
ihnen das gelingen was man jetzt von ihm
erwartet nach diesem langen wahlkampf
die partei hinter sich zu vereinen und
auch möglicherweise in der frage der
diskussion der csu wer ist jetzt ganz
vorne dann gestärkt zu werden also ich
glaube dass er vom typus her geeignet
ist es zu schaffen das ist exakt der
politikertypus der er integriert der er
zusammen für der zuhört das was vorhin
von ihnen als weich beschrieben worden
ist könnte man ja auch als sensibel
integrativ bezeichnen also diese
fähigkeiten hatte alle ich glaube aber
dass ein ganz banales faktum ihm
schwierigkeiten machen würde dass die
zeit also er hat wie es richtig gesagt
wurde nur noch zwei monate knapp zeit
das zu schaffen denn dann stellt sich
die cdu auch die bundes-cdu in gewisser
weise schon zwei mal zur wahl in zwei
wichtigen bundesländern uns sehr jetzt
schon intoniert was passiert wenn das
krachend verloren geht oder jedenfalls
nicht überzeugend gewonnen wird und das
ist ja auch die strategie derer die
laschet nicht als kanzlerkandidat sehen
lasst ihn doch schön in rheinland pfalz
und baden württemberg verlieren und dann
kommt unser lieblingskandidat und das
war bis vor dem
alltag in der cdu tatsächlich auch eine
möglichkeit für märz das ist es jetzt
glaube ich nicht mehr
jetzt würden sich dann alle augen gen
süden richten und irgendwo in amberg
nürnberg auf einen willigen mann treffen
da wird es jetzt auch nicht so schwer
sein diesen namen zu erraten slink
meinen also sie sagen dass die zeit zu
knapp ist für anwender schnitt um
nachwuchs und zwar bevor ich bin da war
ein bisschen kurz konnte es nicht
ausführen ich glaube halt dass das
einzige was seine partei ein und das ist
übrigens auch die 51-jährige ist eine
lehre aus der 51 jährige geschichte der
cdu als regierungspartei ist erfolg ob
die einleiten können oder nicht ob der
kantig ist oder nicht ob der net ist
oder nicht ob der katzen grau oder sonst
was macht es vollkommen egal es müssen
zählbare erfolge her und deshalb ist es
glaube ich eine ganz einfache sache
es ist rheinland-pfalz und das ist baden
württemberg und wenn lasse dort
sozusagen als parteichef am sonntagabend
positive ergebnisse für könnten kann
also welche die nicht nur eher positiv
findet die wirklich selbst erklären
positiv sind was möglich ist
ich habe dann wahrscheinlich eher als in
andern fall ja aber es ist es ist
möglich setzt nicht völlig außerhalb des
spektrums diese annahme
dann wird er der kanzler kann also wenn
wir uns die kandidaten anschauen und
sagen
seine verhört wird ich glaube ich also
wenn dieses eintreten würde dann wird er
der kanzlerkandidat und dann können wir
alle mal sehen wie schnell die cdu
hinter ihm vereint ist weil dann ist es
der mann der wahlen gewinnen kann der
mann der nach vorne geht der mann der
verspricht auch bei der bundestagswahl
gut abzuschneiden und machen wir uns
doch nichts vor
cdu-politiker cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete
setzen doch auf den mann von dem sie am
sichersten sind dass ihr mandat bleibt
in der nächsten legislaturperiode
und wenn sie das gefühl kriegen das ist
der mann aus nürnberg also markus söder
dann werden sie den nehmen also da muss
schon jetzt ein bisschen was kommen von
admin lassen in denen nehmen ist durch
die frage muss ja auch frau münchen
markus söder muss dem ja auch irgendwie
etwas abgewinnen können bisher hat man
ja nicht das gefühl gehabt
sie sind
sie wissen dass selbst am allerbesten
sie sind aus tutzing am starnberger see
zugeschaltet wer im schönen bayern lebt
der zieht ungern weg was machen denn die
ambition von markus söder in sachen
kanzleramt will er das wirklich will er
nur als notnagel eintreten wenn in der
cdu etwas den bach runtergeht was meinen
sie
also da ist tatsächlich auch in bayern
durchaus rätselraten auch im umfeld von
söder es gibt zwei lager
es gibt die einen die sagen der ist so
ehrgeizig
er wird es machen und es gibt die
anderen die sagen er hat so ein rest
respekt davor dass es im grunde für die
csu natürlich ein völlig also eine
hochriskante geschichte wäre in die
bundespolitik zu gehen für söder
weil im grunde die csu damit ihr
alleinstellungsmerkmal dessen diesem
alleinstellungsmerkmal verdankt sie ihre
bisherigen bayerischen erfolge und es
ist immer diese gegenposition zur cdu
und zur bundesregierung zu haben selbst
wenn man teil der bundesregierung ist
das hat die csu in der vergangenheit
immer geschafft das würde man natürlich
zwangsläufig damit aufgeben weil die csu
sich selbst gegenseitig schlecht
internen konkurrenz machen kann wenn es
in der bundesregierung den bundeskanzler
stellt also da gibt es leute die
ernsthafter vor waren einerseits und
andererseits sagen das wird söder nicht
machen aber meines erachtens zu der
frage wird er es machen die erste frage
wird sein wird ihn die cdu tatsächlich
fragen und daran habe ich meinen
allergrößten zweifel und herr
herrenknecht hat es ja vorher formuliert
den zweifel aus der cdu heraus man wird
ihn nicht fragen und das ist unabhängig
vom wahlausgang in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz den mann nun wahrlich
nicht armin laschet allein anlasten kann
dazu sind die beiden cdu-kandidaten in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
bekanntermaßen zu schwach herrenknecht
nicht nur armin laschet auch markus
söder gilt ja inzwischen als mann der
mitte also das ausgleichs nach allen
seiten muss auch nach allen seiten offen
sein die csu es ja auch eine
der heterogene partei können sie da mit
einem kanzlerkandidaten sogar besser
leben als mit einem kanzlerkandidaten
laschet danzig ich würde es als negativ
anschauen wenn die cdu mit 32 32 prozent
sehe somit fünf prozent nach denn die
kanzler position und die csu auf gibt es
wäre eine aufgabe von der cdu selbst ich
glaube wichtig ist dass die gemeinschaft
zu schließen märz zu integrieren dann
einen guten wahlkampf zu machen ein sehr
gutes ergebnis hinzulegen in baden
württemberg gegen kretschmann
das ist die richtung wo dann auch
entscheidet nach zwei monaten ob jetzt
laschet reingeht oder nicht und ich
glaube dass wir gut beraten wenn er noch
zusätzlich den mittelstand mit
integrieren wird und dass wir das was
wir bei ihm vermissen weil er in
nordrhein westfalen nur trost firmen
hatte und ganz kleine firmen und wenn
jetzt sammelt die impfungen erfolgen
dass wir aus der pandemie rauskommt dann
müssen wir alles einsetzen dass die
wirtschaft wieder läuft keine
steuererhöhungen keine vermögenssteuer
und der der für sowas steht bin ich
überzeugt und auch was ich vermisse bei
allen kandidaten wir müssen endlich eine
agenda 20 30 auf den tag legen
die digitalisierung bürokratieabbau das
ganze system die leute brauchen eine
führung ohne führung und ohne vision was
in zwanzig dreißig es nachher können sie
eine partei nicht führend und können sie
auch soll mal der land nicht führen
wir sind in einer unheimlich kritischen
situation eingeklemmt zwischen amerika
und china im sandwich hier drüben und
dort brauchen wir eine vision der der
zuerst raus kommt mit einer vision
20.30 der wird die leute nach der
pandemie führen können und während es
soll ja vielleicht längst die großen in
der dieser globalen fragen sich das noch
nicht sehen sondern sind noch bei der
kanzlerkandidatur sie haben habe ich das
jetzt gerade richtig verstanden wollten
uns noch erklären warum armin laschet
auf keinen fall bundeskonzert ja ich
glaube herr herrenknecht hat ungewollt
den richtigen begriff genannt
es ist nämlich der begriff der führung
der begriff der führung wir müssen uns
bewusst machen wir kommen in hoch
personalisierte wahrheit
der mann der führung gegenwärtig
jedenfalls nicht in dem maße verheißt
auch in seiner ganzen an seinem
auftreten weder über die präsenz des
letzten jahres geschweige denn auch auf
dem parteitag hat sich nur als
teamplayer dargestellt ist über die
persönliche strecke gekommen ich bin
armin laschet mein name ist allerdings
brillanten war eine rede mit der er die
parteibasis gestreichelt hat aber es war
nie eine rede die deutlich gemacht hat
ich übernehme führung und ich habe den
anspruch in diesen zeiten die natürlich
nicht sagt das völlig zu recht
knallharte zeiten sind geopolitisch hoch
dramatische zeiten sind den anspruch
führungsqualität auch als figur führung
zu verkörpern gegen hat lacht und das
ist ein großer fehler gewesen seit dem
letzten jahr eher noch verspielt er hat
führungsqualitäten in der korona
pandemie autorität das ist ein ganz
starker begriff den hat er die hat er
nicht aufgebaut und deswegen ist doch
der witz der wie entscheidet die
entscheidende basis ende märz die
bundestagsabgeordneten die ist
gegenwärtig sind und die gerne alle
wieder bundestagsabgeordnete werden
wollen das sind übrigens die
bundestagsabgeordneten csu die übrigens
auch noch ein geschwisterliches wort
mitreden werden und es sieht sind die
von der cdu
sie entscheiden nicht nur nach der frage
wer ist die größte chance sich zu
entscheiden haben der frage wie
entscheiden nach der frage welcher der
beiden kandidaten mit die bietet mir die
größten chancen in den bundestag zu
kommen und da die bevor münchen gebe ich
ihnen sogar in einem punkt völlig recht
weil die ergebnisse obendrein ende märz
für amila städten nicht berückend werden
weil nämlich zum beispiel in baden
württemberg eine ausgesprochen schwache
kandidatin der cdu aufgeboten wurde frau
eisenmann hätte herr merz zum beispiel
mal den spitzenkandidaten im baden
württembergischen landtagswahlkampf zu
wohnen werde gleich weiterziehen können
sie werden die wahl aller voraussicht
nach verlieren rheinland pfalz warten
wir es ab da die baldor vorne vielleicht
holt v3 aber nochmal auf gewinnt diese
wahl auch dann kommen zu dem schlechten
image von einlasse dass er jetzt schon
hat keine führung
keine autorität kommen noch schlechte
wahlergebnisse und dann sagt den
cdu/csu-abgeordneten das herz
endgültigen die hose und dann kommt und
das ist die eigentliche crux nachdem wir
in der cdu zwei parteien haben wir haben
den autoritären märz führt er seine
eigene partei eine autoritär vor allem
auch wirtschafts radikal
wirtschaftsliberal aber auch mit einer
klare kante figur danach der weiche
typus laschet und da gibt es eine figur
die ziemlich eine synthese darstellt
nämlich einen sozial hochgradig sicht
der grünen sich gerieren da plötzlich
schwarz grün aber mit klarer kante
ziemlich daher kommen da markus söder
der nämlich auch ziemlich deutlich klare
kante kann der übrigens auch im osten
ziemlich gut ankommt und es werden sich
in dem augenblick wenn alles auf dem
spiel stellt alle die
bundestagskandidaten kandidatin hoher
zeit zu markus söder flüchten und dann
trifft eine autonome entscheidung land
ist aber ja einen machtkampf um diese
position vorprogrammiert zwischen
laschet und söder ist das neue ist klar
habe ich das sagen ich glaube dass eben
nicht das ist der witz herr laschet wird
froh sein aber erreger werden das ist
doch egal in dem ort decken sie von
allen verstanden habe auch merkel schon
vor 20 jahren liebend gerne kanzlerin
geheuer damals nahm ihnen herr koch und
viele viele andere namen von merkel die
entscheidung musste dann im letzten
moment haben alle noch vor augen musste
sie nach wolfratshausen pilgern und das
gleiche wird herr lasse weil er die
autonomie dennoch hat gut machen frage
ob es möglicherweise auch anders laufen
könnte er hat ja eine enorme kondition
mit laschet er wird oft unterschätzt er
war ja auf den punkt fit ja selbst
gesagt die rede was sehr gut gewesen auf
dem parteitag ist das eine steuer
qualität eine auch wie gesagt eine
politische kondition eine langstrecken
kondition die möglicherweise in dieser
frage helfen wird aber sie nennen erneut
schon indirekt die zeitachse das mag
sein aber es muss braucht jetzt ein
sprinter und zwar und zwar einen mit
richtigen kräftigen oberschenkeln der
schnellen fahrt kommt und der auch jetzt
mal themen aufmacht die polarisieren und
sich klar zu etwas bekennt und deshalb
ist in einem komischen sandwich er hat
den steigen söder der des brillant krank
und er hat die kanzlerin von der sich
nicht ablösen kann
thematisch als ihr wiedergänger und
macht man nun auch nicht als der
vorsitzenden
seiner kanzlerin gegenüber ich weiß gar
nicht woher jetzt die themen und die
strategie kommen soll
die ihn erkennbar als starken anführer
der cdu in die zukunft gehen lässt und
das muss ja schon mindestens bis märz im
kreuz haben dass die cdu-abgeordneten
beziehungen mitglieder und die cdu
glauben dass er dieser mann ist sonst
rennen die scham weise zu söder und das
weiß natürlich söder längst ich darf an
eines sich davon eines erinnern markus
söder hat seine sein mantra satz mein
platz ist in bayern ja am wahlabend
verändert in das initiativrecht liegt
beim cdu-vorsitzende lange er hätte auch
am wahlabend noch sagen können also am
parteitags auch noch sagen können meint
platzes in bayern
er hat sich bereits geöffnet das war die
offene bewerbung an alle
bundestagsabgeordneten an alle cdu laut
hey leute ich bin der mann den er
braucht ich bin euer märz ich bin euer
märz der heißt dann halt söder ist aber
quasi der typ märz und das glaube ich
wird sowohl das ostalb moment aushebeln
dass der märz den osten bin und denkmal
an ein pärchen das mal erfolgreich
aufgetreten ist das auch sehr
unterschiedlich war gerhard schröder und
oskar lafontaine
ich weiß nicht es hat nicht lange
gehalten dann das dass da kein papier
dazwischen passt armin laschet neben
friedrich merz die behaupten wir sind
ein team da lache ich mich kaputt frau
münch lassen jetzt bitte frau möglich
als erstes und dann herrenknecht erst
von münch bitte ich würde gern noch mal
auf dieses argument zurück kommen von
der angeblichen bereitschaft der cdu
abgeordneten sich jedem der ihnen eine
mehrheit bietet ein heim zu stellen und
mit dem sich zu verbünden sprich mit der
csu in dem csu-kandidaten solange die
umfrageergebnisse
bezogen auf den bund nicht baden
württemberg und nicht rheinland pfalz
sondern bezogen auf den bund so lange
die die chance geben dass die cdu csu
gemeinsam die stärkste fraktion stellen
und gemeinsam den kanzler stellen
so lange wird laschet den vorrang haben
und das wird sich dann so schnell
entscheiden das meines erachtens
überhaupt nicht dass angetragen bekommen
wird und ich sehe nicht diese
abwärtsbewegungen die herr von lucke
prophezeit hat weil die
umfrageergebnisse insgesamt der union
zählen und da kann herr laschet er wird
nicht das überragende ergebnis liefern
aber ein so dass der cdu csu wenn sie
geschlossen ist die kanzlerschaft bringt
gut diese sendung heute diese phoenix
oder die wenn man sie im archiv
besonders markieren und im sommer noch
mal genau ansehen wenn es dann zur sache
geht herrn knecht sie wollten sich dazu
auch noch äußern
klar also ich bin heute überzeugt in der
heutigen situation unsicheren situation
wenn klassik raus kommt mit einer agenda
oder zukunft 20.30 und das dokumentiert
ganz knallhart digitalisierung
bürokratieabbau wir deutschland führen
möchte dann hat eine chance auch
bundeskanzler zu werden keine diskussion
die bevölkerung fragt nach einer führung
und die bevölkerung möchte mit der
pandemie schließen schulen schließen
möchte wissen was passiert mit
deutschland 20.30 und wie wir aus dem
tal kommen wie wir den mittelstand
mitnehmen nicht nur die grossfirmen wie
wir uns weltweit verhalten und wenn
logic auf den punkt setzt habe eindeutig
gefühl dass meine meinung über den
knappen baden-württemberg knapp
verlieren oder nicht spielt keine rolle
wenn wir ein gutes ergebnis erzielen hat
er dann die chance nach oben
durchzukommen
das würde ich ihn empfehlen
und dann gibt es keine diskussion mehr
ich glaube sie überschätzen der
herrenknecht völlig die möglichkeit
programmatisch in zwei monaten auch
angesichts der medialen situation mit
großem aplomb eine bevölkerung zu
erreichen
die gar nicht willig ist große konzepte
in dieser kürze der zeit auch noch gar
parteiprogramme warte ich sehe eine
einzige chance eine echte einzige chance
und das ist dann doch wieder friedrich
merz der im spiel wäre wenn es richtig
also nicht sehe das so dass armin
laschet autorität viel zu klein ist viel
zu klein ist
er hat sich hat deswegen auch die
trainer bemüht es wurde keine troika ist
war eine amputierte troika ist nur ein
kleines du die einzige chance von armin
laschet gab es schon mal eine troika da
war auch der schlechteste der schwächste
dann der kandidat der war aber da hatte
aber das pech dass die cdu noch stärker
war
heute ist die spd und der rest ja so
schwach wenn es tatsächlich friedrich
merz wäre der anstelle oder bereit wäre
dann jetzt diese troika komplett zu
machen und laschet könnte jetzt
auftreten und sagen jetzt habe ich meine
truppe die mir am anfang versagten ich
habe sie mit den zwei gescheiterten denn
jens spahn wir haben gar nicht über ihn
gesprochen anscheinend muss man nicht
mal entsprechend glaube ich wollte
sofort nein er ist jäger aus dem tante
milla sparen was wird sich denn ersparen
ist ja per se ja es gibt dass es gibt
doch das tandem in dem sinne nicht mehr
laut spahn war lange zeit ein möglicher
kanzlerkandidat er hat sich ja quasi mit
dem parteitag selber rausgenommen aus
dem rennen es erledigt jetzt haben sich
zwei in gewisser weise erledigt habt
nicht ersparen erledigt und das hat sich
im märz erledigt durch seine frau auch
ein stück weit in der partei ich glaube
die chance der cdu dann auch stark
gegenüber der csu aufzutreten wenn man
diese troika zusammen brächte und
laschet jetzt für sich reklamieren
könnte ich bin zwar nicht selbst der
mann mit der harten kannte aber ich habe
ja meint friedrich den schick ich dann
auch im osten nämlich friedrich merz und
ich hab den kann sparen
der allerdings auch jetzt mit dem frage
schon ein stück weit an an flügel
verloren aber trotzdem wäre es ein
gebilde was ein stück weit im dem
laschet die autorität verschaffen könnte
die aus eigenem recht licht hatte und
dann wüsste ich nicht ob die csu so
stark wäre wenn ist dieser verlangt der
cdu gebe ich wäre das ab ob die csu so
stark wäre was dagegen halt zu halten
das müsste sich aber und das sei das
entscheidende es müsste sich in den
umfragen auch nennenswerte
niederschlagen und das ist glaube ich am
schluss die entscheidende frage holt
laschet ein stück weit auf oder das team
laschet ist der eindruck der das nicht
20 prozent ist eine riesige kluft
gegenwärtig zwischen denen die bilder
zum kanzlerkandidaten wünschen übrigens
auch in der cdu csu mitgliedschaft ist
eine erhebt das ist haben wir gar nicht
gesprochen erheblich mehr menschen in
der cdu/csu wollen herrn söder
das ganze kandidat herr herrenknecht ist
eher die ausnahme herr laschet wollen
weit weniger
das heißt wenn es laschet und vielleicht
dem team laschet nicht gelingt diese
reputation in zwei monaten zu schaffen
dann wird so der meine sache des kanzler
kann ich weise darauf hin noch zwei
minuten ich würde gerne den sack
zumachen der sendung mit einer frage die
auch was die dass die wahlchancen der
cdu und überhaupt der union angeht
stichwort merkel bonus glauben sie dass
der der cdu bei der bundestagswahl jetzt
unabhängig davon wer kanzlerkandidat ist
helfen wird der märkte bundes ist ein
merkel bonus und der glaube ich hilft
nicht ich glaube ich nicht vererbt schön
da kann man es nicht sagen
nein das sehe ich anders ich glaube ist
bleibt ein erheblicher restbestand bei
der cdu einfach weil sie ein stück weit
die merkel partei geworden ist und ein
ganz schlechtes wort das ist ja
bezeichnend heute wir reden eigentlich
nur über den zukünftigen kanzler war
ernsthaft andere konstellation außer dem
kandidaten der cdu csu nicht in betracht
kommen weil die anderen alle zu schwach
sind ja nicht ganz kurz r gibt es für
die union um einen merkel bonus in
diesem jahr
ich würde sagen geht merkel hat zu
gewinnen durch die damals immigranten
und sie verloren durch die pandemie
zugenommen
das gibt tut sich ein schub für die cdu
keine diskussion cdu/csu und ich glaube
immer noch dass glock wenn er im
programm
20.30 vorführt dass er dank gewinnt das
förmliche sie haben das letzte wort ja
den gibt es fand keine großen fehler in
der pandemie bekämpfen passieren dann
bedanke ich mich bei ihnen bei
professorin ursula münch bei martin
herrenknecht weil claus strunz und bei
albrecht von lucke liebe zuschauer
ich möchte sie auf eine sendung am
kommenden montag noch hinweisen unter
den linden kommt dann aus der kz
gedenkstätte ravensbrück anlass ist der
holocaust-gedenktag in der nächsten
woche das thema erinnerungskultur in
deutschland mit dem titel im namen der
opfer moderiert von michaela kolster
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit michael
krons thema unter anderem die haben es
in der sendung auch schon angesprochen
die bundespressekonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin zum thema corona bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]